I got an email that said hi we're
developing a fully autonomous race car
would you like to be driven around the
most famous track in Britain by a
computer
sure Robo race is an organization
specializing in autonomous racing we
develop our own autonomous race cars and
we run a competition for teams to enter
to develop their own autonomous driving
software we're basically trying to
further autonomous driving technology
through competition now I'm not used to
anything like this I have never been
driven at speed around the track by a
human and I've never been driven at all
by a fully autonomous car this is the
dev bot 2 designed to take a human
passenger now the stats aren't
spectacular by supercar standards 362
horsepower from two electric motors top
speed somewhere around 135 miles now
although
azzam a civilian I'm limited to 60 and
it will take 4.1 seconds to get there
but this is only the development version
this is the version that still carries a
human unlike its sleeker cousin over
there Ronnie is robocar this is fully
autonomous there's no room for a human
whereas the dev bot gives us the
opportunity for human versus machine
type challengers it's actually got the
same powertrain on the rear axle as dev
bot it's just also got the same
powertrain again on the front axle so
it's four-wheel drive it's got twice the
power it's the car we use for our top
speed run we've actually had it up to
299 kph the sensors on the two cars are
actually the same we use a
military-grade GPS accurate up to about
two centimetres so the car knows exactly
where it is
we've got lied arse basically on the
corners of the car and on the sides to a
position where were the objects are
around the car the third is using
cameras and that's using stereo vision
to judge depth basically in the same way
as a human does with their eyes so I'm
about to go for a lap of Silverstone a
national circuit just over one and a
half miles which will take around 90
seconds from a standing start once we've
created a map of the track to say these
are the edges this is where you're
allowed to go we load that into the car
it then has algorithms to determine its
optimum racing line it then chooses what
speed it can go and when it needs to
brake when it needs to hit the throttle
based on accelerations and
knows what it can achieve from the tires
now I know because I've never been on a
track before that on that first turn my
brain is gonna think that we are coming
in too hot and it's not going to turn
and I'm just gonna need to have some
faith that the system is working and I
don't need to take over control because
I am almost certainly a worse driver
than the computer in this car
basically when you're trying to do
something for the first time we need to
be very safety conscious
we have full live telemetry so we can
see exactly what the car is doing at all
times and we have link to that what we
call a safe stop system basically button
that can turn the car off at a moment's
notice from anywhere the car can also
knows to turn itself off if it
determines it's too far off the line
it's supposed to be on and it doesn't
think it can get back there it will shut
itself down moving to drive now and then
moving out onto the track we've had a
few crashes over the last year and this
has been our first year of competition
one of the crashes that we had was
basically a hardware issue the hardware
failed and that led to the car believing
it was in a different place to where it
actually was so it acted accordingly to
go to where it thought it should be but
that was based on bad data which then
meant the car hit the wall
all right I'm lined up and I'm gonna
take my hands off the wheel and put them
here and take my feet off the pedals and
put them on the footrest to be clear we
are not going to be going over a hundred
kilometers an hour here 60 miles an hour
because there's a human in the car and
that's what we're limited to but
acceleration braking and g-forces not
limited okay ready to go all right so we
will get our side so if you're happy
we'll get ready finished happy is a
relative term but yes I am ready to go
all right copy that so ho tight we'll
launch in three two one
okay all right and I'm being assured
that this car is not just following a
pre-programmed line it knows the best
racing line to take of course
it knows the track it's been taught
where it should go but it is reacting in
real-time to attract conditions to the
fact that it's slightly slippery because
of rain earlier and the fact there is
alright the fact there is all that is a
perfect racing line the fight there is
about 70 kilos of terrified wet meat sat
in the driver's seat because that's all
I am right now it's the computer doing
everything here and it sounds like an
electric car the steering wheel is just
moving for me this is astonishing we've
actually had various event formats to
our first year of competition we've had
a race with multiple cars on track on
the same circuit like a traditional race
you've also had competitions that are
far more on a time trial basis just
trying to find different formats and see
how what's on of us racing can really
work to you the cars are identical we as
a company running all of the cars the
teams basically just provide a driver in
normal motorsport that would be a human
being in this case it's a few thousand
lines of software code so if you program
your car to go faster for a corner and
get a better exit from the corner you
will be quicker on the straight you will
be able to overtake whoo and that's
really what it's all about we really
wanted everyone to focus on the
autonomous driving rather than the car
setup thank you returning to base the I
does have information given to it on
where the other car is what the other
car is doing but at the moment that's
mainly been used for safety purposes we
can control the car from the control
room but we do that has company for
safety reasons the teams are not given
any access once the car has started its
race it's only what they've already
programmed
so that was a lot of fun that was that
was wonderful
III had a great time but I also feel
just a little bit underwhelmed because
it didn't feel like there was any risk
there and of course there's no risk
there like I'm a civilian they're gonna
limit the car they're not gonna push to
the edge but that's because there's a
person in the car and that's what
motorsport is about motorsport is about
humans pushing themselves as close to
the limit as close to the redline as
they can and without the element of risk
without that person in the car I I don't
know if it'll work as a sport Robo races
is gambling they can move the audience's
attention from people in the car to
people in the pits and like yeah that
was a lot of fun but it's a heck of a
gamble the whole business model relies
on a successful sport which relies on
people watching it so it has to be
entertaining we're kind of a strange mix
between a technology development and an
entertainment business and I think there
is actually a lot of human element still
within this although it's machines
racing it's people creating the code for
those machines something that is
forgotten in traditional motorsport in a
form of one team there's a thousand
people you just only hear about the two
that are in the car so here all the
human stories are really about those
people in the background how they've
coded the system and they're still
pushing the limits it's just arguably in
a safer manner curve isn't a human in
the car if it does go off thank you so
much to all the team at Robo race find
out more about them by pulling down the
description um
I heart still guy that was only 60 it
felt so much more than 60